this is a secret santa yeah this is my
secret Santa if I had Travis
oh
the first reveal Travis hot dog can you
bring the garbage can over here [ __ ] as
he did just about this possibility yes
he did yeah how do you feel uh uh Travis
that what you did you were on Thursday
annoyed at the idea of uh let's see how
it goes okay can we make a guess of what
you think it's gonna be go ahead what do
you think what do you think I don't know
oh you have no idea it's gonna be
something either with your mom sure
something about you being a smug
[ __ ] sure I mean he just made those
jokes in the bit then again that really
jokes I mean we he I mean that is Travis
though no I mean I love you but you are
a smug momless [ __ ]
he offers no other window into his
personality it would be somebody who
knows Travis that is a great Point
that's true which one we'll start with
this one okay then unwrap this one and
then go there what else does Travis need
an arm shaver
my arms are great yeah maybe a bunghole
trimmer for manscaped okay it is a Ultra
Mega you know what this is gonna be
great when I go out in Staten Island
let's see what is it let's get a picture
wow good for you you got him a red hat
that says Ultra Mega Dennis is getting
very dry I almost did it let's put it on
take a picture that's almost as good as
you know what I might region you want to
re-give well let's we're doing white
elephant let's wait and see who you got
who knows maybe this is look at that
okay uh the gift first yeah the envelope
will go last that was a nice gift that's
nice gift ultramaga yeah Travis is ultra
magnet to my wife
[Laughter]
let's see uh what's in this
what is that
underwear Underpants
is that underwear it says awoken
he's awoken don't drop it
[Music]
with an optional ladies attachment I
wasn't sure what kind of genitals Travis
had that's very smart very nice very
great gift very much
conscious of these things I hope you use
that in studio just because you don't
feel like walking yeah I mean I'm very
busy I sit here all the time that is a
great gift that's a great gift Mike you
knocked it out of the park especially
because
can you believe he was are you insulted
that he was worried no because it's so
of Travis because it's smart yeah yeah
and shitty
he's going to stay in my office
you're not going to take the montone jug
Jim and I have used ours absolutely weak
bladders road trips maybe I could use it
on the boat plus you can sit and and pee
because it's got the attachment the way
he does yes oh well I like the card yeah
it's the Mandalorian in grogu who's
grogu that's baby Yoda bro baby Yoda
spoiler
it's clear how you can get what you want
for Christmas it's it's clear how you
can get what you want for Christmas
there's nothing cheeky written on the
inside it just looks like Yoda this is
the [ __ ] Vader's dick
a couple tickets to an Orioles here
I hope Travis learned a very valuable
lesson I hope so too what a piece of
[ __ ] yeah and if you value the show it's
on a weekday
a rare morning game
maybe wear your sweater you can wear
your sweater Mike thank you very much
you're welcome boss and do you have
anything else you'd like to say based on
the remarks you made on Thursday I'm
sorry
wow that's a Christmas miracle Travis
just apologize apology accepted nice to
be having this party by the way on the
Christmas elevator can you pipe Up the
Music a little bit what do you want it
louder no not louder but somebody like
oh it's something a little more
Christmassy oh like something with like
lyrics Like Christmas terrible sleigh
bells or something yeah well Mike snaps
Jazzy this sucks you knocked it out of
the parking thank you very much good job
you're welcome that's nice you might get
to see a judgian blast yes
yeah I I thought next yeah you want to
see it's your gift I figured next uh
next maybe we'll see who Troy got oh who
who is Troy gifting now Troy yes
are you nervous Travis just got a great
gift you got a piss drug a mega hat and
he's gonna wear the mega hat to watch
the Orioles play the Yankees that's a
great gift that is a great gift I'm
really happy with my I underestimated
Mike munton so you already know there's
gonna be a limited number of good gifts
here yes one is spoken for yeah has it
made you more nervous yeah of course
okay hot dog has stated by the way he
has the best gift of this show now hot
dog you said on Twitter you were going
to have the best gift of the show Mike
montone just gave a very good gift yeah
it is a very good yeah at the very least
it'll be the best gift I've given during
secrets
that's so different that's a very low
bar okay now you're really changing it
it's gonna be a baggie of dirt and that
would qualify yeah
yeah you said I dare anyone to tell me I
don't have the best Jim and Sam Show
Christmas gift this year anyone who does
Charlie Murphy says wrong well that's
before montone [ __ ] he gave him
pulled his dick out and just started
giving out Yankees tickets that is a
little weird right that's not weird at
all he gave him a baseball fan baseball
tickets yeah and hot dog doesn't think
it's weird when another guy pulls his
dick out that's right I know I didn't
know it's great yeah but I I figured the
only thing I'd be worried about would be
Gem and sorry that's it okay all right
well let's go back to Troy all right we
ready yep uh I have
now if you recall two years ago hot dog
got Troy and Hot Dog's idea of a great
Christmas gift was a picture that Troy
had already hired hot dog to take he
paid for the photo hot dog printed the
photo out put it in a cheap frame and
gave it to him in April if I forgot it
was even for Christmas it was it was a
gift of sentimental value there you go
it was nice but you were paid to do it I
was yeah but the frame you paid for the
frame was sentimental and the work and
the effort you put in to put it in the
frame yeah I ordered it online and the
frame was cheap oh that's unfortunate
this is a cheap black frame of the white
man it was like yeah as cheap as you
could possibly be yeah did it fall apart
no it's on my way out of gold yeah it
was it's your wall I see it but it's a
piece of [ __ ]
well let's see did you decide to you
know change that that course of history
despite or forgiveness I don't know yeah
Troy put him to shame
we got Travis some hot dog AI photos oh
start at the time
AI photos from Luma these are great hot
dog loves nfts panties are photography
buff but he looks like Charlie no not he
looks like you know from The Goonies
it looks like [ __ ] Edgar look how big
his teeth are oh that wasn't exaggerated
there's over a hundred photos oh you got
the premium package I did because there
was a couple shirtless hot dog photos
that I wanted to get in there they did
an AI unfortunately so I had I tried it
multiple times but I do have Choice
selections so we'll look through a
couple of oh these are Troy's selections
but he's getting all 100 all 100 124.
wow
all right so let's let's flip to the
next one that doesn't look at me at all
he does you look like uh is that your is
that yeah you don't have that necklace
too you look like a SoundCloud rapper
that's what hot dog thinks he looks like
yeah kind of pensive and curious okay
that looks like what is that I have like
white hair on that yeah oh yeah it's
like a Navy hat oh I love that one this
is a good one that's kind of like a
little bit of a brushed aside hairdo
kind of a sexy young look anime
a hither too I don't mind this you like
this I
[Laughter]
guarantee you that winds up on Bumble I
want that one to be my profile photo
send me that one too that's maybe the
greatest photo I've ever seen hot dog
has a very built chest gold chain he's
got a much better haircut than I've ever
seen him with I have to that's after
completing 60 days in that's what you
would look like after 60 days yes
60 days in except he acclimates and they
go he's not even participating in the
show he's just become a prisoner just
work it out and take an ass yeah
this is Michael B Jordan in Black
Panther yes it is this is very
motivating yeah to be honest you see
what he could look like
that's closer to what you look at my
teeth are on display again yeah you got
gaps in them oh God I am the captain Oh
no I think you just photoshopped that
one no this is all from the internet
oh that's unflattering Jesus
who is that hot dog with another
gentleman that's a fanfic like uh gay
love shot the most true to form yeah
that's awesome
Obama a little bit to me it looks like
my mom when she was younger honestly it
looks like they were both based on hot
dog they're just both slightly off okay
you look giant I look chubby there too
yeah fat
oh that's cool that's a good shot that's
cool cartoonish yeah it's okay
getting in there
oh that's awesome that looks like Drake
that looks nothing like no but it looks
like he's got three layers of teeth like
a shark just highlighting yeah all these
photos yeah
oh my God hot dogs yeah hot dog looks
like he's uh he's climaxing and his
giant teeth are showing yeah hot dog
what does it say to you did so many of
these uh artificial intelligence photos
focused on them Mr Ed Chompers of yours
there are other features that I have
that's true I uh where yeah the AI is
smart working on it yeah yeah I think
there's one more like one more
okay
that's just an actual photo yeah yeah
you got a cool hat on yourself so this
is the gift yeah one more gift he's
taking it out of his pants this is gonna
be uh there you go hang on oh yeah all
right what is it thank you what what is
what is that what's a Viagra Viagra it's
a single Viagra pill you've never taken
one or you have oh no no he's hit me up
a couple times so yeah okay but that
one's on the house is it the Chinese
[ __ ] or is this the no it's just the
generic yeah okay same ingredients these
are widely available via any number of
subscriptions yeah I mean you can just
get it pollute You by entering a code
yeah yeah but this one's a gift and you
put it right in your pocket of course
you did no plastic baggy I would like a
little something what is it going to
dilute no it's just gross it's safe yeah
why don't you pop it now with that beer
I don't know you shut it down let's see
your turgeon fold
I should try herbal erect
always plugging you OD'd on it
well hot dog congratulations how do you
feel about the unflattering AI photos
and Viagra some of them are very
flattering some of them will make me
want to do a couple push-ups after this
are you gonna post them like so your
friends can be like oh hot dogs we're
gonna post this one that might that
might be my profile photo for yeah hit
me with that well you have 124 other
ones yeah choose through we should all
change our profile I would love that I
look amazing there yeah it's damn good
well great job I'm happy great job all
right cool this is an appropriate gift
for hot dogs yes excellent yes hot dog
would love it um you know there was a
lot of uh speculation like there's a lot
yep there's a lot of speculation and you
know we were bringing a a new
body into this uh Grand tradition but
somebody was very detail-oriented
somebody that listens to things that we
don't even remember saying half the time
there's been a lot of speculation I'd
love to hear who Soraya
Drew what name did you draw sorry well
this is a highly anticipated one because
I think there's expectations that this
one may be a good one because it will be
thought thoughtful it will be thoughtful
I got you Sam
all right
now Troy
this is the third part are you starting
to sweat a little bit yeah yeah you are
that was like that it was that that was
a key one right yeah yeah I told you
there's two people here I wanted
and now one of them's gone who is the oh
and the other one was Jim because yeah
this is good for salmon to read for two
reasons oh go ahead number one
high expectations for Soraya yes number
two Sam is the only one in this room who
does not want Jim because I've gotten
him twice and it's always chip
merchandise
yeah well here you go and this is a card
in the front you just flip it I wrote a
mess oh my gosh first of all look at the
detail she's one nice card this is an
incredibly well done card oh you just
flip it over
do you think it would be better if we
just had a tree and just put all the
gifts under there but we never revealed
who they came from no no we're halfway
through the [ __ ] no not maybe next year
no this works every year okay
something what are you asking what was
your sad idea just because it's like
your Secret Santa and then you say I got
this person are you saying we think
would be better yeah
still no Crackdown open today
if she writes something I thought you'd
like wishing you the best always always
always Soraya thank you very much Soraya
you're welcome let's see I'm gonna sway
is a kind soul yes
okay now this already looks like
something that I'd like
okay this is a weight oh my god wow
this is a full-on
Patchwork which I love
denim jacket oh my god with like classic
horror movies on the front the teeth is
amazing demons incredible uh uh uh
zombie what else is over here the Return
of the Living Dead I Spit on Your Grave
terrifier
oh my God look at the icons on the
sleeves oh that's great oh I love this
it's the it's the star of sleep away
camp and it says [ __ ] gender roles on it
I came with it I love that Jason Freddy
Ghost Face what's over here
Candyman Suspiria oh my God and then oh
wow on the holy [ __ ] Saraya on the back
it says terrifier which uh did you make
this yes this is so good and then a
giant Rob Zombie patch on the back
sure it like I will actually like that's
awesome this is fantastic you know I'll
wear it what a great gift you can wear
that to Midnight Mass
this is sorry this is fantastic I'm so
happy you like I I don't like it I love
it oh that's great and let me tell you
something was there ever a doubt there
is no
[ __ ] way
that hot dogs whatever he did not a
chance but wait a minute are you saying
you've already gotten clothing over the
years
I will say this
in all the years that we've done this
tradition
this is by far the best gift I've
received
this is fantastic thank you so much it's
so thoughtful sorry no prob I wanted to
to find a way to do a hard uh movies and
horror music yeah so I and that
Middlesex County sewing class came in
hand you may yeah and I can tell you
like I was sewing up a storm she made
this there's a tag on it this jacket is
the property of Sam Roberts Jim Norton
and Sam Roberts secret Santa gets
Exchange 2022.
show me demons and ghosts from house
so it's the patches from the movie
demons and then under it says and goes
from hell that's great that's fantastic
made it scary
it's fantastic surreya thank you so much
so thoughtful so thoughtful it's a great
gift unbelievable hot dog you're
sweating over there
I do I absolutely want to try it on yes
I I hope it's the right size I I
couldn't remember what your body looks
like lucky you yeah
no yes picture a lizard with a beer it's
perfect it's it even fits perfectly of
course it fits perfectly you people are
gonna ask where they can get that was it
nowhere nowhere because you don't know
Soraya on the on the back I put in in
Japanese that says
holy [ __ ] that's badass that's great I
appreciate that wait till the spring
this is like an everyday I love it
Soraya thank you you know what you can
do you've got you've got a one-of-one
jacket yeah and a cereal one you have a
one-of-one shirt that that you got for
Christmas oh my God what gifts
that's true I do I do do very well first
of all I think it's a one of three
because I think there's a couple in the
Taft house but I do very well with
custom clothing yep yeah you can wear
them all these gift exchange wow
now Troy you've got to be bumming yeah
of course I am
you're upset you're upset great gift
yeah that's a great gift it's really
[ __ ] great everybody's got gifts that
they are that they like and they can use
I'm happy I will get a gift that I
cannot use
that might have been the best gift I've
seen in all of Secrets it's
awesome it's awesome uh
and Sam by the way you look great yeah
yeah it looks good on you honestly I
hate to say it yeah I've ever seen
muscular is that right yeah I appreciate
that Dennis thank you for noticing yes
yeah yeah
um
all right well this that's a tough act
to follow yeah yeah I don't I mean
Travis
I mean I'm not gonna follow that whose
name did you get I got Mr Dennis falcon
Travis got Dennis Falcone
oh who in the past got a uh a very
thoughtful uh rate piece of radio
equipment from Troy that's right that he
made a complete mockery I didn't make a
mockery well you put it on your head and
made robots it was a from a tower from a
transmission tower right you know what
did you what was the noise
does that annoy you when he made that
noise oh I wanted to [ __ ] slam him
through the window
he's an endurance
I found it in during I thought it was
great I did Joe's cute I thought it was
cute
oh now move it how great is this jacket
by the way
how great is this jacket it's it's
awesome and it fits you it fits me it's
my style oh I got scared when I saw it
on the left patch demons it goes from
hell how much do you love by the way
that like with all the great stuff on
this there is the shout out love it and
I was hoping that she put something like
that on there and then all of a sudden I
saw it off of course of course she did
and it's on the front over your heart
where it belongs you didn't have to say
it of course it's over your heart yeah I
thought on Thursday we might be
overselling
your wife's gotta top that on Christmas
she ain't doing it no no she ain't doing
it no
you're gonna sit there wearing it with
nothing else on yeah yeah she's gonna
have to offer me physical Pleasures it's
true all right Dennis uh you can go you
can open the one in the bag first yeah
okay the the only bag in front of me
this bag
Dennis has three packages in front of
him nothing new for Falcone foreign
let's see what Travis got Dennis
[Laughter]
darn those aren't cold because I didn't
want I didn't want to you know and these
are the uh with the Christmas cans big
ones yeah
[Laughter]
12 cans that's good for like four nights
for Dennis oh yeah this would be good
watching yeah get all drunk make
inappropriate political statements to
your daughter open that one this one
yeah okay
all right
are those 12 ounce oh yeah there's 12 I
thought they might be tall boys that
song sucks you don't like this one oh
it's oh
yeah I like this part of it the song is
terrible how long does it take so much I
I don't know he's a little drunk yeah
yeah he's [ __ ] loaded my time he's
trying to figure out how to open the box
can't do it there's no tape on that for
the life of them he's he's trying with
all his mice it's tough tough to do
let's see what's in there oh it looks
like a tumbler of some sort is that a
tumbler Dennis liberal tears
you're gonna need something to drink
those beers with that's right let me ask
you this yeah liberal tears Tumblr do
you think you're it's a yeah it's like a
you could use it though as a as a glass
like a drinking glass too right that's
what's for it's a it's a pint glass
would you uh would you pull that out
while you're while your daughter was at
home for the holidays maybe have a
little eggnog in there watch you sit
down next to Daddy and watch some Fox
News
or you give her a drink in it you don't
tell her what's on it you know here you
go here's a little pop or whatever it's
you drink sure yeah I picked her up from
the train the other day and she gets in
the car and I had a little Fox News 115.
nice you listen on the radio too did she
like that can't miss a moment did she
know it was Fox yeah you think he goes
right from the TV to the radio oh yeah
yep that's the place where hot dog used
to work and fall asleep behind the board
Tucker is coming on can't miss Tucker
you love Tucker don't you Danny
like you know that cat lady made a point
[Laughter]
let's see what's in there the final uh
of three liberal tears glass I love the
liberal teams liberal tears glasses
you really do because he takes his time
but he doesn't do it carefully like no
you can't reuse he's still tearing yeah
he doesn't want a paper cut
shirt
what's the shirt say
like
Brett Kavanaugh
did you rock that one Dennis absolutely
absolutely he said you wear that one I
like beer I still like beer I want to
take a picture of this with your hat
nice okay would you want to re-gift
Dennis's hat to Dennis or bringing this
home oh that's your oh that's okay
that's a family there's gonna be a
family here it's a fairly yeah I think
we're the last people in Staten Island
and not have one yeah yeah
yeah Dennis is going to take a picture
with the hat and don't forget to hold
the cup too I don't know if it's gonna
fit on his little
head yeah that's true you're gonna have
to maybe you can just take a bath at it
yeah
oh yeah perfect perfect and hold the
cupboard
hold the copy [ __ ] alcoholic
yeah
no that's Soraya she's a person this is
the Travis has to the camera it's a hot
dog the big boy
that is Fisher beer
what a good time
what a good time what a good time Dennis
is leaving the Hat on too this is great
this is he ain't getting his back
I think that rifle belongs to you yeah
sorry Travis you just lost your hat
this is why I won't let anyone put my
jacket on Cheers
let me give
okay now look
this couldn't have worked out now let me
give Troy
by the way by the way I don't know this
couldn't have worked out more perfectly
obviously I have no inside information
but we're down to the final four and
Troy has not received a gift the final
four oh no the odds are again wait it's
Falcone yes hot dog myself and Jim all
right so it could go really good or
really right
okay Troy let's say I got you
I've been your friend for how well over
10 years 15 15 years at this point he's
not gonna let you down don't you think
it'd be good if I got your name yeah you
didn't you don't think so no
well you gotta you got a 50 50 shot I
gotta keep that beer in a bag and who
knows maybe hot dog or Falcon came
through for whoever they got we don't
know who that's a great Point who do we
have left that hasn't gotten a gift Jim
you haven't gotten a gift I have not
gotten a gift Soraya has not gotten it
he's not jotting a gift Mike has not got
him Mike has not gotten a gift and Troy
has not gotten
boy
boy
well
let's hit uh
let's hit Falcone next what do you say
we hit Falcone we hit Falcone next
Danny do you like this song
okay Dominic the Donkey
let's see who Falcone got it's
um
one of the all-time fake outs now Saraya
before you open that up uh uh Troy where
does this put your gentle mental I I'm
feeling I'm feeling a little bit better
because now you got a two out of three
because Danny would just phone it in
he's gonna get something nice for Soraya
obviously but for you it's probably
you're probably not gonna like it that
much my guess is probably gonna go in
the trash the sooner you leave here
this is like a Deal or No Deal where
like Troy almost just opened a very
small numbered case right we just opened
it up yes yes now there's there's two
theoretically good cases and one
theoretically really shitty [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that's right but that [ __ ] case has
made the audacious claim that it will be
the greatest I resend that I resend that
card
tweet is out there
yeah it will be the best gift I've I've
given ever again that's not saying a lot
will it be the second best gift of this
year oh Danny finish your beer maybe
third oh God and that's a hot dog
perspective yeah well it doesn't matter
all right we're not that hot dog
cereal would you like to yes should she
open the card first oh the card is very
nice is Danny's mic on yeah yeah thank
you he's not talking
himself I don't know why because he
knows what the listeners want he just
wants to
he loves fidgeting with his yes he does
oh sorry am I supposed to read out loud
yeah
as you
are broadcasting
huh you it's gonna be like a pair of
headphones or something ah something so
stupid oh you already have some great
tools talent and spunk enjoy this gift
and keep your feet on the ground and
keep reaching for the Stars Pump Up the
Volume Denny that's very nice it's
probably gonna honestly that's very
encouraging it's gonna be a Blu-ray copy
of the film Pump Up the Volume I really
like take that message that's a great
move yeah now to the
Christian Slater yeah
okay I think Denny sees himself in a
young eager Soraya he does
this is wildly inappropriate for the
workplace you're right that was a
terrible image to put in anybody's head
Dennis didn't like that one poor her
oh Sony headphones those are very nice
you were right you were right those are
the ones we're wearing right now yeah
you know what when when you come into a
studio you never know who's wearing
these things true those things last like
20 years those are actually pretty good
he probably stole you from here and also
sorry at home I remember when you had
done one of the editing things on your
[ __ ] you didn't have the best audio do
you have good headphones at home now I
do and there you go
that's great they record a thriller with
that yes with those headphones they
recorded with headphones and she's
reading just an egg thank you very much
that dog might be drunk now he is he's
[ __ ] loaded he's eating eggs that's
what do they say about the microphone
the sm7b oh they made Thriller with it
because it's the microphone but yeah who
gives a [ __ ] no one no engineer was
wearing when they recorded threads
they're just offering a chestnut you
know exactly information any more
information yeah all right maybe and
this fell out of the chicken's [ __ ]
a fun fact Troy do you think the
headphones you think you would have
gotten the worst gift in the headphones
yeah of course yeah that's a nice gift
though right the headphones yeah I
wanted to get her something practical
that is nice to us that is and she'll
use it she will use it
I mean quality wise you can't get better
nope yeah I use those head those are in
the number three standard industry
standards those are in the not same
Studio what are they Sony's yeah they're
what you're wearing on your head very
nice yeah there's those headphones that
you have on I have it at home
you did great now uh
we still haven't hit Troy yep Jim
or Mike
I I just love Troy's face when I thought
he was getting a gift from me I fooled
him well Troy your eyes are up you
folded okay two out of two out of three
you got one dud gift remaining two
theoretically good gifts right I
guarantee I got the guaranteed
we'll see I'm gonna go next oh okay I'd
like I'd like to go
Sam you do whatever you want it's your
show I'd like to go next
and I'd like to say Merry Christmas oh
Merry Christmas
to Jim Norton
and I thought to myself
what do you give
to the man who was recently made the
transition in his life transition to Old
Man baggy corduroys oh what would you do
you what could you give
what could you give
okay I'm taking out my pink it's a
little pink I get you okay okay diapers
yeah diapers is a good one adult diapers
would have been good let's see I was
thinking about buying him a bunch of ftt
but this
is
what a lovely gift a nice I love my my
older man sweater cozy older man sweater
yes it's perfect yes I went around and
selected
I think it should fit it's look at him
he tore the tag right off what a nice
thing to do it wow it's a medium
when they were sitting on the couch
nodding out after a Christmas meal with
drool that's right that's right that
won't be drool
see nice thoughtful gift not an
inexpensive sweater either that would
have been nice for that is it medium
yeah and but I wanted to make sure it
was a medium that had you know I wanted
you to have a little room in there is
that not perfect it's wonderful
and it goes with the pen it does that's
what I was thinking of the tan pants
I love it that's your Christmas outfit
thank you glad you love it I'm glad you
love it I love it
very thoughtful we both thought of each
other yes yes now he's gonna go have to
find that and buy nine more yes
now boy oh boy the odds uh the odds just
changed again we're back to 50 50. it's
a flip of the coin yup we've got Troy
and Mike with no gifts that's right
Mike doesn't have a gift yeah everybody
got a gift except Troy and Mike oh I
know who got her
everybody's given a gift
you do yeah I think I just figured it
out why do you think so I just I have a
feeling you have a feeling
what something I recalled Troy would it
shock you that Travis kind of knows
because no we were all here when names
were given that's not what it is
he's he's up this always up to some
Shenanigans nope good call yeah how do
you feel about the fact that like this
whole thing was orchestrated and somehow
you're left here at the end without a
gift how do I why I'm not without a gift
well not yet why do you think they try
to ruin Christmas for you because he's
being ruined you love seeing me have a
ruined Christmas yeah I'm a little drunk
yeah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] sweater
wow I love my sweater Sam you do yes I
thought okay good looks good on them too
it does you guys both look great in your
new outfits I went around I I did a lot
of sweater shopping yeah
you're gonna talk politics later yeah
how happy everybody is you're probably
thinking about that game coming up oh
yeah I can't wait and Soraya look at you
thinking it's a pint glass Dennis
imagine all the things you'll get to
listen to yes look at that and hot dog
imagine all those ladies that are going
to be impressed with your stupid AI yeah
and I'm so disappointed when they meet
up an hinge yeah well
um
I kind of and I'm I'm willing to
hear out
theories but I'm kind of feeling like we
go gym then hot dog
I kind of feel like hot dogs yeah I kind
of feel like hot dog is where you end it
yeah yeah yeah because finale we're in
one of those like do we announce the
runner-up or the winner because we're
gonna know
I think there's way more to discuss
with hot dogs gift potentially he says
it's the best I I you said it on the
Internet it's the best you tweeted it
you tweeted it you tweeted it it's out
there I'm gonna delete it
[Music]
bitterness though I mean
should we say okay all right all right
wait wait
should we say who got Mike who got Troy
I'll I'll go let's just make it simple
okay
Mike montoy yeah
no no
please give that to Troy
[Applause]
oh
my God oh my God
oh my God that's my guy oh my god do you
believe in miracles by the way I now
here's why I thought you might have
figured it out because I'm stupid and I
went oh Mike didn't get his that's why
that's yeah I realized
I got scared I thought I gave I got the
gift for the wrong person oh my God
Troy I mean you have conquered Christmas
I mean whatever it is it's not hot dogs
yeah exactly you deserve this you're
always holding it up like the the WWE
belt yes he was Troy Universal champion
and all transparency I'll tell you how I
knew I remembered when we were picking
names that Mike picked his own name
and Jim and Sam picked first because
they're the hosts so I knew it couldn't
have been Jim because he'd already
picked Mike
and I think right after Mike so he put
it right on top
thank God
thank God you didn't get hot dog slow
down yeah slow down we don't know yet we
don't know what's in that box never
delivered an actual present before you
know it would be great if hot dogs
usually catch better this year like hot
dog came up with 700.
here we go that would be the move for
hot guard by the way did you save all
year and give somebody a thousand
dollars cash
and by the way Jim's a wild card yep
because like you're focusing on when he
gave 300 cash but I've gotten two Duds
from Jim I have a little work because
there is some weight I mean it's not
cash maybe it's gold maybe it's gold Jim
also knows that you really really want
him so yeah
Jim also thought it would be a good idea
to invest in ftt on Thursday
now I hope that this is
oh my God
oh
it's a
Troy Troy what is it
chip uh
woke not broke with the snapping I hope
you like your truck that's a nice shirt
that's a nice thank you very much and
you will wear it I will absolutely wear
it and you were able to get it at cause
ah I was yes oh but did I see an
envelope there was a car there is an
envelope
oh maybe this is where we all hate Trump
read the card of course oh a little make
good
what do we got how much is that Troy
it's a
nice crisp 20.
that's like something you get from your
uncle don't don't tell your mother where
you got this that's what you get for
being greedy Troy oh he thought he was
gonna cash out that's the card Sage he
got twenty dollars in a chip it says
Troy you can't you can't put a price on
friendship
yeah
thank you Jim thank you everybody
and your friends I love Troy yeah I got
the gift of friendship I did get thank
you buddy yeah I do appreciate it Troy
got exactly who he wanted to get you
know what honestly Troy got exactly what
he deserved yeah he got a greediness of
trouble a lot of vanity he got yeah I
hope Troy learned a lesson I've been
waiting six years for Jim and what'd you
get a chip shirt for twenty dollars
are you happy with that gift that's the
greatest gift of Christmas don't spend
it all in one place I've never seen him
happy on any of these shows yeah no uh I
always complaining you know there's two
things you can count on Soraya and Jim
making sure that what is supposed to
happen happens
well I guess we know hot dog yes all
right all right let's do it Cheyenne hot
dog got Mike montone now it's
interesting because uh
Mike montone has been very the only
thing that Mike montone is liberal in is
are his shots so
what's going on I don't know he's
preparing it looks like he has a baby
it's even wrapped some kind of
presentation and he said this was gonna
be it'll probably be better than my gift
it won't be better than Sirius he said
it would be the better he said it would
be the best gift
oh my gosh it's rap first of all the
fact that it's even here for this show
it's more than
usual what's the weight on that Mike and
and keep in mind light to you would
probably be heavy to the rest of us let
me hold it wow single arm overhead uh
watch it I want to see Travis hold it
just to watch him [ __ ] just to watch
him slip a disc
what's the weight on that drive what's
the average weight okay average was that
10 pounds say it's uh one and a half
pounds oh okay what's the uh tag say
[Laughter]
somebody did that to me when I went to
the store the other day they said have a
happy holiday I go Merry Christmas oh
good for you good for you good for you
straighten them right out right if
you're Jewish happy happy Hanukkah which
began last night Sunday shout out yes
shout out to all my Jewish friends he's
good and [ __ ] Denny's oh my gosh
anticipation big white box could be
something from MILF Island Troy's gonna
be so mad
[Laughter]
there's no [ __ ] here there's no gag
gifts these are this is just a very well
I mean you've never done gag gifts it's
always just [ __ ] people yeah I always
think that it's a good people gag
because they're nauseous
yeah hot dog always thinks it's a good
all right it's a thing of some sort whoa
it's got a very nice case on it
a Firma a firma
what is that what's a Firma we're about
to find out
it's like an off-brand erectile
what is a firma
oh
this is absolutely something that hot
dog would buy another man
what is it is a uh it's a massage gun
well you go to the gym you get you know
what
you get sore talking about I have one of
those it's it's a green by Mike a
massage
it's an amazing for your loins and all
that good stuff oh this is something
good this is something seriously it is
practical
yeah
contains a user's manual that heavily
features the male physique
hot dog did you buy Michael massage gun
it's very practical he goes to the gym
but you might need somebody to help him
do he's gonna use it on him
you could use it on yourself and also if
you need some help with it I I can show
you it is for self massage you could
show him how he could come over here
well I mean Sam's secret santa I got so
much what you want it's about what you
get it's about what's in the heart I
know like wait hold on I will show you
how to use it do you want to show them
how to use it
it might it might have to be charged but
but like I mean we got time I look at
this jacket right and I go oh I want
this like if somebody were like oh yeah
I want that to get the sweater that I
got I love it I actually love this why
wouldn't you want a massage I mean it's
literally because Jim said he wanted it
and I go oh I remember Jim saying he
wanted that that's gonna and when I
mentioned the chip shirt Troy's eyes lit
up
Mike aren't you like sweaty and then
like sore after a nice workout so this
isn't helping your kids
that's why you're the other Dad yeah
right
Travis yeah do you want your baseball
tickets like more than anything can't
wait it's okay because there's another
GIF there's one oh it's nice I did I did
want to point to the number of pro
different
yeah it loosens up your thighs the back
of your calves this looks like it was
supposed to be delivered to a lesbian
orgy in the Jersey Shore hotel room yeah
I remember that movie it's a twofer hot
dog I will find a way to have fun with
this or massage myself thank you very
much I I hate to say it I called it up I
hate to say it but I do have one of
those those are great it's a great gift
demonstrate on Mike
[Laughter]
yes crack that cold one open this one's
for Uncle Dave it's got a nice weight to
it too for Uncle Dave this is gonna get
weird the first one was for Uncle Dave
yeah
I have your beard Denny yeah have some
beer
I mean tear that up with your big
muscles dude
this is getting so homo erotic drunk
yeah he's letting his freak flash
lightweight
it might get even more homo erotic what
is that well are you familiar with a
fashion designer who in the late 90s was
murdered by uh Andrew Andrew yes Versace
what okay there's something from Versace
I like the Versace Versace Versace I am
a man of classes a man of many sense
classy is this from Canal Street or as
Elizabeth Berkeley in Showgirls said
Versace that's right I can't even
pronounce nothing all right
those muscles
he just said Lube those muscles he said
Lube those fingers up what's going on I
don't know I think I know what this is
this is a gift what do you think it is
why would you get him Versace cologne
why would you get them cologne and a
massage gun well I think there's a very
clear yeah it's a rhetorical why did you
get in this
hold on okay all right all right maybe
we're doing the DVD of the Al Pacino you
guys would be wrong
what's in there sunglasses Versace
shades not color it's not cologne wow
it's very nice I guarantee you they're
fine they're not absolutely guarantee
you their eyes are like 700 glasses
those are valid retail 300 where did you
get them retail I got them online from
where they're so fast don't worry listen
they're [ __ ] fake dude no no they're
like you look great but they're fake
they are not they're legit they're legit
there's like also there's a way to
verify it it's all in there you can go
to the Versace
I'd like to know how much you pay it's
retailed at 300. ah just leave them [ __ ]
just leave you got it Below Retail
though like a lot below yeah no I did
not I'll tell you what either way hot
dog this is a great pair of shapes thank
you I know you love your shades are you
wearable time man on the street these
are legit look it up they're fake they
are good Rick you look great they are
100 legit yeah they are not of course
yeah they're knockoffs I spent good
money on this
no no you're not taking this away from
me I hope that hot dog spent a lot of
money on them and they're fake
I think that's exactly what happened to
tell you the truth I think hot dog spent
over a hundred dollars on fake Versace
shades over 200 yep why would you do
that if you're gonna spend two hundred
dollars why would you just spend it on
some Versace sunglasses instead of
putting like that's there's zero thought
put into it you could have you could
have given anybody in the room Versace
sunglasses Mike Montague likes he loves
sunglasses more than anyone else in here
how do you figure that mangle dies okay
they're 146 on Amazon all right how do
you know those are the exact same ones
because I put in the item number yeah
did you lie when you said you spent more
than 200 no it was you lied about 54
clams well in combination
do you think you lied about spending
over 200 oh yeah there was no wait 146
with tax it was 180.
yeah it was about 180 and then and then
plus plus the massage thirty four
dollars in tax there's no way plus the
massage gun
how much to check out traffic
let's check it out and see what the time
relax hang on but you see what I'm
saying about thoughtless right like just
because it's like one of those gifts
that just is expensive you cannot win uh
that's all right he's drunk
this is why you don't want to drink
Soraya this is why yeah
okay well let's okay all right hang on
do you think what do you think a hot
dog's gift
I think the sunglasses look very nice
they're nice right Mike okay well let's
ask this let's test this
I know there is no thought no it is
sunglasses sunglasses he says he likes
sunglasses when evidently he knows when
did he ever say go out for man on the
street the carrot picture wears the
character wears sunglasses the character
wouldn't wear Versace
well he will now they're fake they're
not fake you can look it up it's 159
after tax yo why'd you say 180 why'd you
say two well I guess well I did he said
there's a man who was shipping and
handling they spent over 200. here's a
key question
highly appreciative of your effort this
is going to be an enjoyment it's so
stupid it's so dumb you still want to
see hot dog demonstrate let me ask you
this choice we got it you've seen
there's you there's USB
right Troy yes hot dog went crazy this
year he's like I'm gonna spend money I'm
gonna make it the best gifts I've ever
gotten Jim gave you a chip chipperson
t-shirt and twenty dollars are you upset
that you got Jim instead of hot dog or
the gym got you
I did say I wanted Jim I got what I
asked for but with this gift like do you
think this is a good gift that he gave
Mike
I wouldn't want it what the [ __ ] what
does that mean and you know you want to
gotten fake sunglasses as well there's
nothing specific to Mike about those
songs if I got those sunglasses I would
have smashed them right here because you
knew they were fake yeah because their
phone your face they're not fake you can
go to this website get them down on
Canal Street yeah hot dog I saw him down
there and there's there's nothing
specific to Mike about those sunglasses
nothing
very specific he looks great in it
anybody would look great in them they're
fake for something because they're
awesome they're designed to look great
well I think they frame a very chiseled
jawline yeah I wouldn't look as good in
those Michael my
thank you
you might get some green on the side of
your face not fake I don't think gym
never really takes a bad photo though
you look great you know why because
everybody does yeah
I mean you could have you could you
could have bought those sunglasses
before you drew a name sure that's a
great shirt
like somebody who's never even listened
to the show or met Mike montone could
just give him fake Versace sunglasses
they're not welcome to fake
and also uh what are the other gifts
that came I mean I'm amazing I made
basketball tell me one gift that wasn't
specific to a person tell me one gift
there wasn't thought put into besides
yours
I mean tell me one
um I mean the headphones could have gone
she's starting in radio yeah all right
okay well I mean the uh the uh the uh
Troy as much as I love your gift that
could have gone to anyone no it couldn't
have because it was a chip shirt it's
funny that Troy is specifically
and those muscles
why didn't you like your gift no I love
it
that's I am arguing my point
saying that you gave the worst gift
okay all right hot dog yes we should go
around the room because it's become a
theme those are real
you're saying you did not give the worst
gift this year
I think it goes to the gym what do you
do
what are you doing Log Cabin
Dennis Falcone
come up Dennis's truck Dennis is drunk
and he finally can't handle anymore
these traps the thing of fantasies
I didn't know we had those
three just received a very feeble
geriatric background was it was it
satisfying it lacks the amount of
pressure that I'm certain that gun can
provide yeah how is how is Dennis's uh
grip strength
need a longer finger I think for that
job small hands wow you do have little
tiny hands you do you do what a sweet
boy Dennis yeah he is a little voice if
those shades are fake you can look it up
there or go whatever I will give you 300
cash what maybe I prove that those are
fake now I want to find a way to prove
that these are fake I mean that's twice
what you paid for them yeah because
they're not fake is what I I don't I
don't like these allegations
I mean
I would just go out of your way to or
okay you know what you do Mike go buy
some fake ones do we do we have an
appraiser just like voice know a guy I
got you right now they're clearly fake
they're not fake the box was even in bad
shape no it wasn't it's all taped
together no no no no no the person that
I had do like do the gift wrapping tape
would you have to get forever yeah
there's a service over by my job service
you went to a service you do it yourself
it was free it was complimentary
do you think they switched out the
glasses while he wasn't he just walked
in with glasses they they I left my
gifts and I said come back in 30 minutes
and then oh those things guys
did you check them
did I accept them no it's like a free
compliment you have to tip them yes
that's why they're doing it well they
knew and I would attempt it they're
doing it for charity yeah it's like the
church does that yeah yeah
I saw other people go come in and come
out for a reason you always tips it's
because it's a couple of Americans yeah
it's complementary to the what to the
building
what building the mall what mall where I
work where my job is they work at the
momentary gift wrapping Place yeah the
church like does that yeah they work for
donations yes donations I you should go
back and give Escape 20 bucks yeah and
and ask for your sunglasses back yeah
we got another month
I don't think it's fair to say Jim had
the worst gift because it was you know
part of it it's it's for the show the
show it's the fun of it yeah Jim put
thought into it and said what would be
the funniest thing here what would I was
just what's a good gift exactly yeah
that is a great gift no it's not of
course it is
of course it is if you got that on the
Christmas tree montone you would have
been like this is nice awesome you have
to explain yourself to me you could put
it under any Christmas tree are we
charging it
massage
give him a massage during the break time
yeah Denny's
are up to Snuff well let's
Danny needs the crap which is the true
worst gift of Christmas I would argue
I'm gonna make this argument
there's no way it's me I got the best
gift of Christmas I believe you did
absolutely of all time you think so of
all time it's amazing I want that you do
right I do want that honestly do I look
badass yeah you do thank you not salmon
Japanese on the back that's so [ __ ]
sick
yeah don't say that Dennis yeah me and
my friends are hosting a secret santa if
you would like to come
you're you're involved okay so if we all
agree who got who and I'm I'm very
blessed I think you Soraya that's all
your yes you get the credit the
headphones were like you know we were
goofing around but I think thoughtful I
love my gift I'm wearing it it's very I
really appreciate that it's soft I
appreciate that Troy your bit was
hilarious and obviously you enjoy it
because you're wearing the shirt God
bless us everywhere got the who gave
my Mike Travis got base baseball yeah
see Travis got the gag and then the very
thoughtful gift what seats
you know what the best part about those
tickets is they're not fake they're not
fake let me tell you something I'm not
gonna tell you exactly where they are
but they're aisle seats and that is
[ __ ] that's good in case you always
get ice 43 46. so who who gave the worst
gift
ask if he paid 346 I'm in the section
okay who I mean somebody I don't think
you could
because I don't think anybody in the
room can hurt someone yeah yeah can we
start with this I this is the best gift
I've given that's not what you said but
can we start with that I think he's I
think he's able to it is
other gifts it's better than the other
gifts sure okay we'll start with better
than the nft yeah yeah who gave the
worst gift in the room
are you nodding we're all kind of
thinking I mean you know what nothing
this was that's the most honest person
she's sire
don't do that we need this because all
right don't you want to know I do
because we all have our biases and we
also we like putting people in the
barrel but yeah is pure and honest and
that's why it's just it's not what
Christmas is Daddy drink your beer sorry
you gave the best gift of Christmas by
far and so you have the privilege of
honestly telling us
who gave the worst gift of Christmas
then I will I will remember this that's
fine hot dog needs nothing you don't
have to worry about it yeah no no no no
he'll remember this you just have to
pray that you don't get him or he
doesn't get you next year I mean even if
you say he got the yeah he'll give you a
shitty gift regardless it's not shitty
it's real it's shitty it's gonna be more
fake Versace
the worst everything was good yeah okay
everyone did great bye
and even perhaps a gift that you may
think uh is like like everyone got a
gift I think that was appropriate even
if it was not what you were expecting
yeah some of them not everyone
I guess I would say who gave the worst
I hold The Grudge
you don't nobody cares I'll tell you who
I'm between right I'm between
Cheyenne for best worst
[Laughter]
this is how women talk about his penis
I'm between Cheyenne and
gym only I love that somehow Troy is not
the worst
because that that's 100 AI photos and it
is appropriate yeah that's more than hot
dog deserve how many clicks was that
I had to go through it twice I told you
that yeah plus Cloud that's exactly for
posting them I guess and I did put I did
want it to be a funny gift that Jim put
thoughts into it yes yes I I guess I
guess I'll go everyone did great I guess
I will go with you Cheyenne only because
it's
[Music]
it's not about the cost of the item so
even if you guys let me in the eyes when
you say that
you got really
really sunglasses it would have thought
of sunglasses just sunglasses yeah but I
still think that Mike are you gonna use
that massage gun are you gonna wear
those Shades I am oh there so what are
we complaining about literally you could
literally ask anybody the same question
I could give anybody a million dollars
and you would have said that's the best
gift of all time personally well these
weren't worth a million dollars
well Jim gives 300 in cash no yes
does he give 300 cash no he didn't
notorious for giving the most generic
great gift very generic 300 anyway I
would say this 300 cash is much better
than the gift that you gave Mike oh yeah
you can do whatever you want let me ask
you this Mike what would you rather have
those sunglasses you're wearing or the
cash value
I mean obviously the cash value and let
me ask you this if you had the cash
would you spend it on those sunglasses
no but a gift is something that you
wouldn't normally buy yourself would you
buy those sunglasses and if and if the
answer is no is it because they're fake
no I mean I usually get my shades in
bulk on Amazon so this is a huge step up
either way hot dogs on Amazon too let me
tell you it's probably the best Amazon
came in and gave Mike 300 he would have
been King [ __ ] yeah 100 oh okay
if you want to save yourself let me ask
you this array if Hot Dog venmo's Mike
100 right now yes venmo me the day he
doesn't have the worst gift anymore does
he
uh no yeah yeah I would go forth with
that yeah I'll tell you this don't I'll
tell you this in my opinion it's only
one man's opinion
between the list price and the actual
price if Hot Dog venmo's make a hundred
dollars his gift is much better than
Troy's gift to hot dog and Troy will
have the worst gift of Christmas I think
if he then most hundred dollars he wins
Secret Santa you think it's better than
this jacket I think it's yeah wow
oh no because you guys just railed on me
for not having a specific gift and all
of a sudden I have to say hello so
you're taking the worst gift of
Christmas
you're gonna take the worst gift of
Christmas again two years ago I had to
venmo four of you guys I'll send you
Mike's venmo
that's okay
[Music]
if you were threatened with possibly
having to live with the humiliation of
giving the worst gift of Christmas you'd
whip out that memo wouldn't you
especially if I had a history of it yeah
I would absolutely pull myself out of
the gutter with a venmo only 100 bucks
like it's getting three four sorry if
this if this jacket had struck out
you'd send the fan mail wouldn't you uh
uh I don't I don't I only use cash
it's even better yeah even old school
even she's an old soul she's 1957
mentality she'll just hand you a few
bucks no it's always nice a savings
bought a U.S savings bond okay we're
attacking Japan
I always got those from my aunts yeah
yeah saving spots what do you think hot
dog what's the move I hope you would die
before they matured
you can make Troy the worst gift of
Christmas
right
Mike's got his benefits I do not have
the worst guns he can actually make me
the worst gift
hot dog could make me the worst gift
because Sarai said it was between me you
know what yes all right
it's a hundred limits hundred but then
what happens okay but then what happens
if Jim venmo's me 200. and Hot Dog's In
Trouble hold on I can guarantee you I
will not Venom Ultra money I promise you
you've given your gift I will not venmo
Troy money I just did a set for you last
night right thank you I will call it a
wash and I'll go ahead put your Vendo
information
by the way you idiots right now need to
take back everything you said about me
mistreating hot dogs no because that
whole thing I was not taking into
account that this guy is like the third
time we've done this wait hold on but
before you do that I am guaranteed not
the worst gift not the worst gift not
the worst gift because that's important
he Apple paid everybody two years ago I
did I know
it's all right I got I'm good for it
you're good for it dude it's not gonna
bounce you're liquid yeah Mike feel free
to add an extra do not do not I do not
do that like like you send yourself
whatever you think
whatever would help ease this trauma do
not do that whatever whatever you think
is gonna make it the best gift whatever
would make the pain of this go away 250
I don't think is out of the class the
holiday season I mean it's not
unreasonable how much is in your bank
account you're cut off at a hundred
dollars hot dog how much is in these
yeah because if I try to overcharge it's
not gonna let it go through how much is
it I'm not telling you that's probably
just go down by ten dollars see if
there's 175 down there you are mapped
out at 100. yeah 150 175 I think that's
fair I I think it's I think 100 I think
20 is more than fair I'd say 100 150.
who gives 20.
you slide me a little bit
slide me a little something something
you know I spent a lot of time
researching history yeah big history
buff yeah the the gladiatorial games the
Roman emperors often oftentimes the
crowd can't go to sleep they would be
they'd be lusting for blood yeah yeah
the emperor could actually score some
points if he showed a little bit of
benevil restraint but we want blood Mike
we want blood yeah we do want blood
down the line
Mike do the right thing do the right
thing Mike
mookie do the right thing I know you're
right do the right thing it's got to be
I mean
175 feels exactly the right round nice
solid 200. you get 200 which 200 would
feel good 200 would feel good yeah I
have faith in you you do the right thing
Mike I'm just I'm putting a nice
Christmas message in Mike has hot dogs
himself taking quite a long time an
amount that he feels well I've read a
nice note okay okay
make sure it's public yeah make it make
yeah it's always something
I love this good job Denny
are we on you're nursing that beer over
there Danny well yeah I'm selecting the
proper Tunes yeah keep going
how about some Christmas stuff is he on
the other one is that open oh okay okay
Mike is writing himself a message
through hot dogs venmo
I'm gonna
open my venmo and see if I see the
message come through
it's taking a long time
yeah and we haven't decided on a final
amount the payment has been sent okay
let's see
okay this says Merry Christmas I
secretly Lust For You Sam and Travis and
it's three eggplant emojis
and the amount is private what was the
amount the amount was one hundred
dollars
you showed me you told the merciful but
what's great is that all of his friends
will see the message yeah will they be
surprised no got a girl yeah yeah so
well guys this was a good one we didn't
see the massage yet it's been truly
magical hot dog why don't you go over
there and massage Mike on the way out
yeah we have uh
there's a Christmas album out uh Dennis
you said we're gonna let's play the
Christmas album during the best of wait
is he going to
maybe it's not charged yet we've got a
lot of best stuff coming up we've got uh
uh this week we're gonna be running uh a
lot of the previous Christmas shows
there you go oh that feels nice all of
the previous Christmas shows will be
aired this week okay and then
who's filming hot dog doing this we
should have this the camera should be on
yeah is the video team rolling on this
nope next week uh we'll be got a very
delicate touch sure Jim and Sam best of
the year you could turn it up okay yeah
there's different levels there next week
will be Jim and Sam best of the Year yes
and this year has been so eventful yes
I'm on the
necklace he's working the nipple yeah he
did graze the nip yeah uh guys I have to
before we go yeah New Year's Eve come
see me at Levity Live yes and uh I got a
bunch of dates uh just go to
jimnorton.com and thanks for listening
this year yes thank you to Soraya and
thank you to hot dog for the best gift
of Christmas we'll see you next year
wait wait wait wait wait I almost forgot
I almost forgot yeah
I don't like being pegged with the worst
gifts
[Music]
oh my God I almost forgot oh my God
how can I forget has the worst gift of
Christmas I don't like that title how
can I forget as we speak here Jim has
the worst gift wait Troy oh well how can
I forget I didn't just have that in the
chamber I can't believe you forgot I
forgot what is it it's another twenty
dollars and what does the card say I
really wanted to just reiterate
I just want to reiterate the thing about
not putting up a price on friendship
that's fantastic thank you everybody
we'll see you next year